butter Cheryl Travis Von Whitson
Williams Vice chairman Leatherwood
chairman Terry Mr chairman we have a
quorum all right thank you and before we
get started do any of the members have
any personal orders
no okay uh see none I do want to make
introduction uh we have uh a committee
attorney that is with us for the first
time this week Miss Caroline Miller
and then uh before we get started I did
want to make uh an announcement and it
doesn't look like there will be an issue
today hopefully but just want to make
sure that we keep the aisles and the
doors clear at all times and if it ever
becomes an issue in this committee we
will ask the sergeant arms to reloc
relocate individuals outside and then we
do have one of the bills that we have on
the calendar today is going to have some
testimony and so it's my goal for today
and for every day and we're committee to
maintain decorum and have an open and
honest debate I ask that members of the
audience also maintain the secorman
refrain from any outbursts
that might interrupt discussion again if
this becomes an issue we may ask certain
arms to relocate individuals outside
um members we will not have any running
domain debates I ask that uh you'd be
recognized by me if you have any
questions or comments
um
and then I said one of the bills on our
calendar today there are going to be
eight people they're going to be
testimony and so it is my goal to give
each person they will have three minutes
to testify and at the conclusion of all
them testifying
um then we will ask the members who have
the opportunity to ask questions and
bring somebody back up to answer those
questions at that point in time I also
would like to make an announcement that
next week we will have unless plans
change we'll have TennCare coming in to
give their budget presentations and then
the following week we will have the
Department of Health coming in to give
their budget presentation and I know
there's a lot of interest on asking
certain questions of both departments
and so uh fair game will be at that uh
at that meeting as well so we do have a
calendar and so we will get with item
number one house bill 66 I think
represent of Butler you are recognized
you have a motion a second
thank you chairman this is a very simple
bill
I do have to point out representative
Martin's
very patriotic UT attire today that kind
of caught my eye it kind of stands out
so anyway House Bill 66 a very simple
Bill the executive order 10 signed by
Governor Lee transitioned the Tennessee
early intervention system from the
program from the Tennessee Department of
Education to the Tennessee Department of
intellectual and developmental
disabilities
and so what this bill does is simply
streamline government we're moving it
from the Department of Education over to
the Department of intellectual and
developmental disabilities and it just
simply streamlines the government and
avoids having any duplication in
government services
do we have any questions for the sponsor
of the bill
seeing none before chairman Williams you
recognized
thank you uh representative Butler I
know this was asked to view in the
subcommittee but I thought since we do
have the chairman of from the District
of Champions here today if this was your
first bill
yes chairman it is thank you
and thank you before we vote on this
bill I do want to make sure you are
introduced to the uh chairman of that
committee and he will
um when he get when you get to the house
floor if you get this bill to the house
floor uh he he will ask you some
pertinent and maybe some not so
pertinent questions
on this bill so all right without the
objection we are voting on House Bill
66. all those in favor say aye
aye opposed eyes have it bill goes on to
calendar rules
all right that brings us to item number
two House Bill 64. chairman Hawk you
recognized thank you Mr chairman and
members I'll give a motion on the bill
your property right recognized thank you
very much many of you will remember
we've put forth
the
tan of Tennessee Opportunity Act in
recent years and we have created and
formulated
through an advisory Council a tremendous
program that's going to bring seven
different pilot organizations across the
state of Tennessee to
formulate new programs and we're looking
to measure the effectiveness of these
programs and in setting these up the
advisory Council has recognized we're
going to need an extra year to get a
report back to the legislature and I sit
on that advisory Council as well by the
way so in the original Law we had put
forth getting a a report to the general
assembly by December 31 of 2025. we're
going to need an extra year just to get
these programs up and running and
measure the effectiveness so number one
the bill will extend the the deadline
for a report to December 31st of 2026 it
gives us one more year to gather data
and measure data as well present Law
requires the Department of Human
Services to within a 12-month period
following the end of each fiscal year to
obligate all the unspent Tana funds out
to community programs this is going to
give us instead of that 12-month window
and 18-month window to get those funds
distributed out to Community programs in
a nutshell it does those two things Mr
chairman and members all right thank you
and I guess yeah to further your point
we basically uh when the bill passed we
had an ambitious timeline and as we've
gotten into work we realized we need a
more reasonable timeline and that's what
this does representative recognized
thank you Mr chairman uh I'd like to ask
if I could two or three questions here
one
um
the funding we're talking about we're
talking about I guess the way I'm
reading this is we're going to push this
money on out and I'm saying what the
rules the guard rails
for monies of this nature
I guess what I'm trying to get at we're
not going to just push it out and let's
sort of just to say we got it out is it
going to be a part of the uh inside the
guard rails of what we already have in
place
thank you Mr chairman there are numerous
guardrails in place to make sure this is
done right what the right way and in
addition to that the measurement tools
that we're putting in place to see if
we're actually having an impact on
families is what's one of the critical
pieces of this and and that's what's
going to take a little more time to
create those measurements so yes all the
gold guard rules are in place as they
have been before okay representative uh
yes
um
are we
are we going to
have reports I think I heard that we're
going to have a report in 2025 or 2026.
I guess if a program needs to be
adjusted along the way uh we're going to
have any information on that or we wait
until 2025 2026.
chairman Hawk thank you Mr chairman and
I will say that the department of human
services along with this Families First
Community Advisory board that we have
organized with seats from all across the
state of Tennessee
we are an active bunch and if something
is is not meeting the expectations uh
and I've had this conversation with
Senator Watson as well along Senator
representative Terry sorry I gave you
the motion there chairman Terry but
along with uh chairman Terry we've had
these discussions to ensure that we're
headed the right direction these pilot
programs have been vetted and vetted and
vetted and vetted one more time to
ensure that they're in it for the right
reasons and doing the right thing if a
problem does pop up we are going to know
about it and and we will in turn share
that with the general assembly if there
is an issue okay one last question
you're good all right
uh let's see the
we have seven I'm gonna say entities
across the state uh
do we have one for Southeast Tennessee
and who serves on The Advisory board for
Southeast Tennessee
chairman Hawk thank you Mr chairman the
original law that set forth the
Tennessee Opportunity Act
indicated that we would have
representation amongst Grand divisions
for the pilot programs and it was set
forth it worked out that each Grand
division would be
um
would be have the opportunity to be
awarded two pilot programs
and then there would be one with
somewhat of a Statewide application that
Department of Human Services would would
offer up to be the seventh pilot program
each of the each of the uh
entities put forth I think there was in
the 30s mid 30s or so the number of
entities who put forth plans that were
all given discernment and vetted and
vetted and vetted once again as as I had
mentioned before
in the six
Regional
pilot programs were decided upon using a
fairly extensive Matrix that scored all
the aspects and all the the pros and
cons of those programs
I can't recall exactly if Southeast
Tennessee was what where they scored but
I don't think they got into the final
six in terms of representation on the
committee and there may be others and
and we can I can get names but I know
Senator Watson is on the advisory
council with me as well so Senator
Watson is on the advisory Council I'm
sure there there is other representation
from the private sector in the public
sector as well there but Senator
Watson's name comes to mind first that
created another question Mr does that
mean that Southeast Tennessee is not a
part of the process or we lumped in with
someone else
you recognize thank you chairman
I want to make sure I get this this
right
there are there are Regional pilot
programs in each Grand division
I don't want to say that Southwest
Virginia is unserved because they're
still being served throughout some of
the processes they may not be part of
this particular pilot what the pilot
programs themselves are we're trying to
think outside the box and find
innovative ways to help individuals
although Southeast Tennessee
organization may not have been one of
those that was awarded a 25 million
dollar Grant over a three-year time
frame they are still very much
participating in the TANF program and
the family's first program to get those
dollars in and again get those dollars
out toward helping families so we're
looking for innovative ways and and what
we asked for we're innovative ways to
reach families that are going to be
measured in detail
Southeast Tennessee is still
participating in the TANF programs to
the degree that they have before and
probably even more so with the
additional dollars that are being made
available but they were not one of the
six Pilots that was chosen
thank you Mr chairman all right thank
you thank you any further questions for
the sponsor okay seeing none
we are voting on
house bill 64.
all those in favor of House Bill 64 say
I I opposed eyes have it bill goes on to
finance Ways and Means
right that brings us to
item number three on our calendar House
Bill one leader Lambert here recognize
you have a motion in a second
famous chairman there's an amendment
that makes the bill that is coded zero
zero three six nine four
okay you have a motion and a second on
Amendment
zero zero three six nine four if you can
give us a brief description and we can
get that bill in proper form
yes sir Mr chairman this addresses some
of the issues that came up in the
subcommittee that some of the members
had asked about
um dealing with some cleanup language
and then specifically with the sexual
abuse and neglect right without
objection Let's uh get the bill in uh
proper form for debate so all those in
favor of uh Amendment
3694 say aye
aye opposed eyes have it okay we're back
on the bill as amended thanks Mr
chairman members of the committee I know
you have several folks here that wish to
testify Mr chairman if you wish I can
reserve any of my comments till after we
hear from the people of Tennessee if
you'd like okay if there is no objection
uh we have some folks here that would
like to testify and so without objection
Let's uh go out of session
okay
um we like I said we have eight members
uh first on our list is a Mr Matt Walsh
if you can for the record uh state your
name and who you're with and you will
have three minutes
my name is Matt Walsh I'm here as a
husband father and concerned citizen of
the state of Tennessee and I want to
thank the committee for allowing me to
speak and for all of you on the
committee who support this important
legislation
now I know that we can't agree on very
much these days but we should be able to
agree that our most solemn
responsibility as individuals as a state
and as a country is to protect our
children we should be able to agree that
children do not have the physical
emotional or mental capacity to protect
themselves or to make life-altering
decisions
we should be able to agree that it's
never okay to chemically castrate
sterilized butcher or mutilate a child
and in fact all decent people do agree
on all these points but many of the
people hold power in this country and
who run our institutions including our
medical institutions do not pass this
basic test of decency
they've made House Bill one not only
necessary one of the most important
piece of legislation this body has ever
taken into consideration
in service to a radical far left agenda
children are being led down a path of
gender confusion and identity crisis
this crisis manufactured by the cultures
and exploited and monetized by medical
professionals who first put them on
chemical castration drugs like Lupron
then the victims are given cross-sex
hormones which often have irreversible
and permanent effects
finally before the age of 18 many of
these kids will undergo surgery such as
double mastectomies which will alter
their bodies and their lives forever
taking something away that they can
never get back
no matter how much they regret it in the
future and so many do
this is happening across the country and
that includes in our state
children are being coerced into
decisions that they are not equipped to
make in pursuit of a goal that that can
never be attained the girl who gets the
double mastectomy is no closer to being
a boy after getting the procedure that
she was before she's still a girl and
will always be a girl just now a
mutilated and damaged one
now you may notice that most of the
people who support and advocate for this
Butchery are not petitioning to lower
the drinking age they're not trying to
pass a law to allow middle schoolers to
get tattoos or take out mortgages or
purchase firearms or cigarettes that's
because even they recognize that miners
lack the maturity and discernment
required to make those choices they
recognize it when it comes to alcohol
and tobacco and guns and mortgages and
Tattoos yeah when it comes to
irreversible life-altering medical
interventions suddenly these same people
discover a new found confidence in the
responsible decision-making powers of
children
their position is not even consistent or
coherent much less morally or
scientifically defensible we cannot
allow this wickedness to continue we
cannot tolerate it we are decent and
rational people in this state we love
our children we recognize basic truths
one of those basic truths is that a
child who is confused about her identity
needs guidance and love and clarity
she does not need hormone injections and
scalpels
she needs she needs and deserves to be
protected from those child abusing
quacks and soulless vultures who wish to
exploit her confusion for their own gain
that's why we need this law our kids
cannot protect themselves but we can and
we must and we are thank you
thank you and if you will
stay in the committee room there may be
questions afterwards second on our list
is uh Jenny Bailey
foreign
thank you for joining us and maybe
either one is but make sure the mic is
on and uh
leader Lambert can probably help you
just for the records record tell us your
name and who you're with
in three minutes afternoon chairman
Terry Vice chairman leather wood and
members of the committee thank you for
hearing my testimony today my name is
Jenny Bailey I am a former president and
current board member of P flag Franklin
P flag is an organization of lgbtq plus
people parents families and allies who
work together to create an equitable and
inclusive World founded in 1973 P flag
is thousands of people and hundreds of
chapters from coast to coast who are
leading with love to support families
educate allies and advocate for just
Equitable and inclusive legislation and
policies there are coordinated outside
forces working to change our state laws
and remove tennesseans Liberties to get
the health care our kids need when they
need it today I'm here to ask you to
support your constituents by keeping
government out of doctors offices
protect transgender kids in Tennessee
just like you do every child in the
state please vote no on hb1 for the sake
of trans kids and their families who
love them I'm here today representing
two Middle Tennessee families who have
transgender children but did not feel
safe to come before you themselves
the first story is from a father he has
spent his entire life as an educator in
Middle Tennessee he States as an
elementary school teacher and then High
School administrator I know the
importance of providing students with
safe stable nurturing environments that
establishes the trust needed to assist
with learning about five years into his
tenure as principal his middle schooler
came out to him as trans he says growing
up is hard enough when someone feels
comfortable with who they are please
don't make it more difficult when
someone knows who they are but are not
allowed to show it the second story is
from a mother from early in her child's
life there were persistent indicators
that her child born with male genitals
saw herself as a girl from the toys and
games she chose to the clothes she chose
when the child got to middle school she
told her parents she was transgender at
this point the parents did their own
research and worked to support their
daughter as best they could quoting the
mother now she says our child
immediately began to flourish however my
beloved Tennessee where my family has
lived for Generations where I have
devoted my entire Adult Career to
investing in children's health and
well-being is also where the leadership
hates me and they hate my child simply
for existing
thank you for the opportunity to present
these life stories to you I'd like to
give you a copy for the record if that's
okay
at P flag Franklin we hear stories like
these every month in our support
meetings from parents and grandparents
who love their children and want
desperately to do right by them and to
keep them alive
please vote no on this copy paste bill
from Outsiders and fear mongers vote no
to protect tennesseans it will be a vote
that is pro-life thank you thank you if
you have any materials you can send
those to my office
um next on our list and please again
stay in the auditorium or stay in the
Committee hearing room in case we have
some questions uh next on our list is
Landon Starbuck
and again for the record uh speaking to
the microphone uh tell us your name and
who you're with
I'm Landon Starbuck um I'm here today as
an advocate for children harmed by
medical exploitation and gender
mutilation
may I proceed yes please
many families have looked to my
non-profit for help finding support and
resources whether little to none
available outside of the affirmative
care model which tells children that if
they don't fit into stereotypical often
misogynistic gender Norms that they are
born in the wrong body one of the most
abusive destructive lies you could tell
a child is that something is physically
wrong with them just because they like
different colors toys hairstyles or
Hobbies all children are unique and
don't need to be on drugs and be
surgically altered to solve a mental
health issue they need therapy they need
to be told you are not a mistake your
body structure does not dictate or
Define your ability to live a happy
healthy life feelings are not forever
the majority of children suffering from
gender dysphoria have at least one
mental health related comorbidity many
of them have experienced sexual abuse
and trauma but instead of using standard
therapy-based interventions kids are
being fast-tracked to puberty blockers
and hormones without true informed
consent doctors and therapists fear
losing their license if they don't
comply with the so-called gender
affirmative model and no doctor should
be coerced into treatments they deem
harmful and scientifically unsound in
some states if a parent affirms their
child's true sex they can have their
children removed by CPS and even go to
jail for five years in Canada
one Young American Girl was removed from
her family because they refused to
affirm her as a boy her mental health
issues went unaddressed she was
separated from her family and her
vulnerabilities made her a target for
trafficking she was trafficked not once
but two times
this is one example showing the most
dangerous outcomes of teaching kids to
keep secrets from their parents
separating families and transferring
power to Medical institutions who have a
billion dollar Financial incentive we're
here because an ideology an ideology
based on social theory has been
unethically medicalized for profit and
Grave human rights abuses are being
committed against children so-called
gender-based medicine is actually
lifelong dependency on the Medical
Institution and pharmaceutical companies
there's no consensus and there's no
ethical experiment there uh Theory based
on theories on children especially when
the experiments include dangerous
medications used off label with zero
long-term safety studies no empirical
studies and children left with lifelong
debilitating irreversible side effects
puberty blockers are not fully
reversible if a child goes on puberty
blockers for five years those critical
years of development are gone their
bones don't gain any density boys
genitals don't grow girls breasts don't
grow and their pelvises don't expand Dr
Marcy Bowers a sex change surgeon
admitted during a Duke University
meeting recently that she doesn't know
of a single male that was able to
achieve orgasm after their medical
transition we're talking about children
here minors their future Intimate
Relationships their fertility their
sexual function obliterated the
pro-mutilation activists argue that it's
about affirming a child's identity but
yet children are encouraged to have a
sex change before they've even had a
chance to develop their identity
including sexual development
thorough follow-up studies based in
Sweden of trans adults show that 10 to
15 years after sex reassignment surgery
yes that's three minutes okay all right
thank you
and if you again can stick around we may
have some questions uh for you all right
next on our list is Daniel Simmons
thank you for joining us today if you
can for the record uh tell us your name
and who you're with in the microphone
and then we'll start your clock
foreign
thank you thank you my name is Daniel
Simmons I'm a youth Advocate at out
Memphis and I am a current student
studying psychology and gender and
sexuality studies at Rhodes College all
right thank you
hello thank you for hearing me today
um I am testifying against House Bill
one on the grounds of my personal and
professional experience
I understand and respect your hesitancy
and concern regarding the surgeries but
I am testifying today asking you to
reconsider the ban on hormones and
puberty blockers I ask you this as a
transgender individual who underwent
gender affirming care as a minor
two years ago I would have been impacted
by this bill being heard today at the
age of 14 I was confident in my trans
identity and I came out to all of my
friends I conducted my own research and
I had to wait until I was 16 in order to
seek medical treatment
before my first appointment with the
gender Clinic I was asked to supply a
referral letter from a therapist during
which and later during the appointments
with the gender Clinic my mother
grandmother and I all underwent
psychological evaluations to ensure that
we collectively understood and were
confident in the decision to go on
hormone replacement therapy
after we were after I was approved for
replacement hormone treatment
um there was an additional six-month
waiting period which is standard
practice at the clinic to be certain
that this Clinic that the patients
continuously presented dysphoria over
that period of time in summary it was
almost three years between the time that
I came out as trans until I was able to
receive gender affirming treatment
for myself and others in this situation
The Waiting was literal absolute torture
I woke up each day hating myself and I
went to bed wanting it all to end it
felt as if I was constantly fighting
tooth and nail just to stay alive and I
wasn't sure that I was going to make it
to 18. one question that's been
previously asked in discussions of this
bill is what is the harm in waiting
until the child is 18 to make the
decision
I respond that there is a very specific
type of pain in knowing that there is
Treatment available that will help you
to see yourself as you are and for other
people to see you as you are and being
denied the right to access that
treatment
the time before medically transitioning
was a social and mental torture for me I
couldn't make medical I couldn't make
meaningful friendships and I wasn't
being perceived as the person that I was
something that hurt more than the words
could say
I didn't feel like I could make friends
because it was inauthentic and I even
became more distant with my family
they weren't becoming friends or
learning more about me as a person they
were learning about a false shell that
they were perceiving
since beginning hormones and laterally
and later surgically transitioning I've
been more confident and more at ease at
myself and more able to communicate and
Advocate with my peers
my grandmother remarked after I began
medically transitioning that she now
goes to bed every night listening to me
laughing and talking with my friends
which is something that she don't
doesn't think that she'd ever heard
before
she couldn't comprehend the impact that
gender affirming care had for me until
she was able to actually see it play out
the bill that is currently being heard
will ban all health care for Trans youth
surgical intervention hormones and
puberty blockers the cost of waiting is
torture and I've seen it time and time
again in my own story my peer story and
the peers or in the stories of trans
teens that I've worked with as well as
in the stories statistics and research
that I've been a part of in college
Mr Simmons that's three minutes thank
you thank you
all right uh next on our list is Dr Omar
Hamada
and for the record talking to uh delcr
on the microphone and who you're with
hi I'm Dr Umar Hamada I'm a board
certified OB GYN and family physician uh
also with uh specialization in sports
medicine from 10 years combat service in
the US Army Special Forces
um also with the theology degree from
Seminary
um
Pew researched Forum last year came out
with a poll that said that the
transgender population in America makes
up 0.3 percent of those who are 50 years
and older it makes up 1.6 percent of
those 30 to 49 years of age and 5.1
percent of those 30 years and younger
what this demonstrates is that our
society has seen 17x increase within a
single generation
the number of those identifying as
transgendered between 13 and 24 years of
age has doubled in the past five years
scholars believe that this radical
increase is due to a number of factors
such as intentional grooming and
desensitization coupled with the added
power of suggestion in this precocious
age group we see that in this Society in
general with grooming of our children
through popular video games like SimCity
and even here in various County School
Systems even in Williamson County where
kindergartners in elementary schools are
sent home
birthday books which have non-binary
primary characters to be read and then
returned with a nameplate dedicated to
that child whose birthday it is
acceptable Medical Practice has long
held that the treatment of psychological
and emotional disorders is psychotherapy
in its many forms as well as
antidepressant antipsychotic and anxiety
medications never before have we
insisted that irreversible and permanent
medical and surgical mutilation of a
child's physical sexual characteristics
be part of this equation during this
very volatile time in their lives
aside aside from the surgical mutilation
of children many Advocate puberty
blockers and sex hormone used to begin
the transition from one gender to
another these medications when given to
pubertal children do significant
physical and psychological damage many
of the effects are reversible but many
are not
today our European counterparts in the
UK Finland and Sweden who were all well
ahead of us in these areas have begun to
put the brakes on as they see more and
more resultant problems than benefits
gender transition surgeries for
adolescents have increased five-fold
between 2016 and 2019.
in the past gender transitions were very
rare
most adolescents with gender discordants
resolve themselves within a matter of a
few years however once gender affirming
care so to speak has started the
likelihood of completion is much greater
than many come to regret it and here's
the kicker over and over we have seen
that there is no reliable evidence that
these treatments result in improved
mental health decreased rates of suicide
or increased sense of self-worth or
identity over the long term or that the
benefits of transitioning minors
outweigh the very significant medical
Surgical and psychological risks it is
true that this group is more susceptible
to Suicide than the Baseline population
but this does not change with
transitioning there's no scientific
support the gender corrective surgery
reduces the risk
I do not like the idea of a legislative
body dictating medical treatment however
in this case when we have failed as
physicians in a society it's up to you
to mandate such protections to our
children thank you
thank you and if again if you'd stick
around in case the panel has or the
committee has some questions uh next on
our list is Mr Greg schweiger
foreign
thank you and again and for the record
uh tell us uh your name and and who
you're with
we have three minutes I'm Greg schweiger
i'm the dad of a transgender Son thank
you
I grew up the youngest of six on a
Kansas farm where we went to mass every
Sunday my dad was a career farmer who
served on the school board of the ruatan
was a 30-year volunteer fire chief he
showed me that service to others is
necessary to support a healthy family
and Community now I'm the proud dad of a
transgender son in Tennessee
on the evening our son came out to us I
immediately told him I loved him no
matter what then I asked what he needed
our first job was to help him socially
transition change his name speak with
family friends into school secondly we
sought help from the team of healthcare
professionals including pediatricians
gastroenterologist and endocrinologist
dermatologists and nurse specialists and
dedicated psychologists
we researched best practices and we
trusted the medical experts who had the
best interests at heart
this complex years-long process took
time for listening learning consultation
therapy community and many many
thousands of dollars all of these things
we gave freely with love
and through all of this I never wavered
I I do what all Dad should do fight for
the child provide for them and be the
best dad possible today my son is a
brilliant successful college junior
which not would which would not have
been possible without his gender
affirming care
hb1 will force trans kids and their
families like mine Into Darkness with no
medicine no expert help and will cause
nothing the pain suffering and death
from the beginning we were 100
supportive and loving our of in our
son's Journey still that took time
intention patience and included a long
series of medical experts who could not
do their job their well-researched
life-saving best practices when this
bill passes I cannot fathom where my son
would be today if he did not have the
access to health care he did
it breaks my heart
I think back to what I learned from my
upbringing what it means to be a dad
what it is my responsibility to protect
a child help him become the best person
that he can be and to ensure that there
is a supportive community so that he and
others like him can Thrive but here I am
in front of those who falsely claim to
be Servants of Tennessee yet spend a
questionable amount of time trying to
hurt the most vulnerable children I
cannot understand how anyone especially
the dads in this room can work to pass
laws that will only bring praying and
suffering to Children and Families
because to me strong loving dads fight
to protect their family and their
Community for everyone I'm telling you
as a dad do not destroy families with
hb1 let's support each other don't let
Tennessee be a place where children have
to be resilient and strong and brave
just to be themselves all right thank
you Swagger time is up
if again if you can stick around we may
have questions thank you for your
testimony
next is uh Prisha Mosley
and again thank you uh for coming if you
can tell us who you are and and who
you're with and then you will have three
minutes
all right
um my name is presha I'm uh with myself
testifying on behalf of gender
non-conforming children I'm testifying
today as someone who has was
transitioned as a child as a
detransitioned adult I recognize the
importance that civil action laws like
this would provide in holding the people
accountable who did this to me as a
child and preventing other children from
being harmed when I was 15 I was 15
years old when I learned about gender
ideology from the trans community at 17
I was being medicalized with a high dose
of testosterone one year later my
healthy breasts were cut off I had
pre-existing diagnoses of anorexia
nervosa anxiety panic disorder major
depression and borderline personality
disorder I also experienced a sexual
assault at 14 which I was under the
impression only happened to girls these
other conditions and issues were all put
to the side when I uttered the word
gender my therapist even attested that
all of my problems were caused by by
being born in the wrong body this wasn't
true but I was medicalized anyway I was
deemed stable and well despite multiple
recent suicide attempts active cutting
and severe malnutrition during the time
of my transition I also asked my doctors
for liposuction they told me no because
I was too well to have an elective
cosmetic surgery but decided I was
healthy enough to have my breasts
removed now at 24 I have two huge scars
where my breasts should be and no
sensation but the occasional zapping
pain I feel my body is disproportionate
causing me to be clumsy and ugly I have
no hips and large shoulders my neck back
and shoulders constantly burn from the
overgrowth my throat is sore and I can
no longer sing or raise my voice
jeopardizing my safety and taking my joy
I have suffered hair loss as well as
hair growth on my body which I have to
treat with laser hair removal my muscles
and joints ache I decided that I did not
want to be a woman before I had ever
gotten to be one I was a little girl now
I will never fully know what that is
like I fully support a bill that
protects youth from the undeniable harm
caused by so-called gender affirmative
care
thank you very much and again if you can
please stay there might be questions for
you thank you
and last on our list is an Elliott
Atwood
thank you for joining us and uh as with
everybody else tell us who you are and
who you're with and once you do that
you'll have three minutes thank you
thank you representative my name is
Elliot Atwood I'm here on behalf of
myself and other transgender youth in
this state
um along with my mother
I'm 17 years old
I attend a public high school in
Williamson County
I'm actually from Mr whitson's District
my most measures I'm the pretty average
kid I love shop class I hate homework I
sing in the Men's Choir at my school
well because like any kid from Tennessee
music is my life
I've got a pretty good group of friends
too we're small but we're like a family
I'm a happy guy
but my life wasn't always this cheerful
in my freshman year of high school on
the second day of school I came out as
transgender
I had known about this I'd known this
about myself for a while my whole life
really and I knew that it was time to
share that side of me with my classmates
things were Rocky to say the least
a lot of people had never met a
transgender person
it took time for things to get better
I kept to myself I minded my business
and people learned to do the same
I wanted to start my medical transition
for a while
there are a lot of steps to getting a
prescription in Tennessee it's
especially when you're a minor like
myself
my parents were very hesitant in the
beginning as were my doctors
but by the time I turned 17
my fam my parents were starting to come
around
all of the doctors in my area had
stopped accepting new patients out of
fear from this bill
the process is a slow one and providers
are cautious
I've known who I am for most of my life
and still I've not been able to access
this type of Medical Care
medical decisions especially ones as
delicate and important as a medical
transition should be between myself
my parents
and my doctors
I only ask that the state of Tennessee
continues to allow me the normal life I
deserve as a resident
I'm gonna be 18 soon
and this law won't affect me
but I can't help but worry for the
teenagers out there my friends who were
just as I was
will they even make it to 18.
I ask you to vote no on this bill
you think that you're protecting people
like me but you aren't
you're hurting your constituents
taking away our Medical Care won't
prevent us from being transgender but
it could prevent us from being safe
healthy and happy
I thank you for your time
all right thank you and I appreciate all
those that testified today and we may
have some questions here I believe
chairman face on do you have a question
question thank you Mr chair and who who
would this be directed to would you like
to come up if I could ask Mr Walsh Mr
Walsh if you would mind uh
Matt thank you for being here you're
recognized
just a quick question for you we've
heard in the news last week
and even today that
it's pro-life to vote against this bill
we've heard that um
suicides are prevalent
and suicide has impacted my family so
I'm sensitive when I hear something like
that
I I I've read some of the stuff that
you've done and I was wondering can you
speak to the statistics
of of
Mental Health
and Suicidal Tendencies
for the people who have gone through
transition for people who have not in
your studies from what I've read can you
can you speak to that I'm sure you
recognized sure uh well the claim that
uh you know doing the chemical
castration drugs or surgery or hormonal
intervention the claim that this
prevents suicide or uh has uh positive
psychological effects down the line is
utterly totally baseless there are no
credible long-term studies that bear
that out and one of the reasons for that
is that there couldn't possibly be any
credible long-term studies because we've
never done this to kids on this scale
ever before in history so this current
uh shall we say crop of children they
are the guinea pigs this is this is all
experimental we're sort of trying it out
on them to see if it works now they have
attempted a few times to do studies and
the interesting thing is that the world
Professional Association of transgender
Health wpath which is a radical far left
pro-trans organization they commissioned
a study to try to prove that um that
hormones and puberty blockers a
decreased suicide rates among
trans-identified Youth and even in their
own study they found that they couldn't
they couldn't they couldn't prove it
they couldn't make that link because
it's just not possible to do the other
thing I would mention too is that
you know the the
number of trans identified youth has
skyrocketed in recent years we're
talking about exponential 10x 20x growth
just huge numbers having of a have
increased and what we hear from the
pro-trans side is that well this is not
a social contagion it's just that you
know there's always been this many trans
people it's just that they were not in
an affirming
uh environment before in history and so
they couldn't come out and now for the
first time trans people have have the
ability to live their truth so to speak
well if that's the case and there have
always been these sort of like millions
of trans people and if it's also true
that if we don't affirm them that it
would cause them to commit suicide then
we should be able to look back in
history and find just this unbroken
incredible epidemic of children
mysteriously killing themselves because
they weren't being affirmed as trans and
what you find is that that didn't exist
I mean the the youth suicide rate has
increased exponentially alongside trans
affirmation so trans affirmation causes
the suicide rate not the other way
around the last thing I'll note is that
um
the suicide rate among trans identified
people is is Sky High it remains Sky
High all the data shows us it remains
Sky High even after surgery and in fact
in the most reliable day that we have
it's a years after surgery when
suicidality is the highest for
trans-identified people that's the
reality
replacing you good okay any further
questions for Mr Walsh while we are out
of session uh Mr Hammer Mr
representative Hammer thank you
um thank you Mr Walsh I found it
interesting one of our uh uh people
testified today that they uh had their
gender affirming surgery at 16 and I
know uh you and former comments
mentioned uh this on your blog at about
16 you're an adult who's mature and can
make decisions uh you're that at 16. I
don't care what anybody says even going
so far as to say you know 16 people in
your 16 you should be married and uh and
could be pregnant or should be pregnant
so I'm curious if 16 is uh a uh an adult
in your view why is this bill have the
minor defined as 18.
yeah that's that's a hit piece you took
from Media Matters uh from something
when I was a radio host uh 13 14 years
ago in my early 20s uh it's also not an
accurate reflection of what I actually
said I was talking about
uh the fact that people tended to marry
young historically and that's all that
that was about
um
how does that relate to this
subject
just curious your definition of if you
feel like people are adults of 16 should
people are adults at 18. but actually
they're your your brain is not fully
developed until you're 25.
so we should be having a conversation
about whether we should even be doing
these surgeries to people at 18. but
certainly before 18 it's it's absurd
I mean do you do you think that a 16
year old can meaningfully consent to
having their body parts removed
do you
no
we do not yeah we ask the questions it's
not it's
okay uh representative Hammer you are
recognized
no more questions okay uh representative
Clemens you recognized
yeah thank you Mr chairman
um can you give us a summary of your
educational background or your health
care education experience Mr Walsh you
recognized my experience in healthcare
your educational background I'm just
curious you you testified as to a lot of
your own research so I'm curious for
what purpose you do that and what
background you have to qualifies you to
speak to that well my background that
qualifies me to speak to this is that
I'm a human being with a brain and
common sense and I have a soul
and so therefore I think it's a really
bad idea it's a chemically castrate
children that is my experience
um also I I did now it's true I didn't I
didn't go to college but I did go to
school long enough to learn how to read
so I could read the data for myself and
that's exactly what I've done
representative Clements here and for
what purpose do you um conduct your
research and use this brain of yours Mr
Walsh you're recognized
I use it for the purpose of trying to
protect children from being castrated
and mutilated that's one of the things I
try to do
thank you Mr chairman you don't use it
to get clicks on your State application
well using it right now to try to get
clicks with this interaction
on no I I I I I I really like the idea
of getting uh of of drawing attention to
the fact that this is happening to
children I know you seem to find it very
amusing I don't
representative Clemens
well you made a lot of
misrepresentations and and category
characterizations in your comments I
think it's fair for me to question your
background
let me finish please
you're recognize representative Clements
you know if you're going to come before
a committee and make
mischaracterizations and
misrepresentations it's a fair game for
us to ask you your educational
background and your foundational
knowledge for making such
characterizations that's that's my point
so I'm curious about you speaking to the
development of the human brain by the
age of 25 I seem to recall you
advocating on behalf of firearm
possession at the age of 18. do you
think that's what let's stay on the bill
please
that's all I got okay yeah well uh can I
respond to that
representative Mitchell you'll recognize
I can't respond to them yeah thank you
Mr chairman so
you know you I think your original
article blog post or tweet or whatever
kind of started this Firestorm so I'm
trying to figure out you know where we
need to look for these surgeries because
I'm still trying to find you know the
surgeries because you know the the
sponsor of the bill last week I kind of
agreed with him I said we need to split
this bill into two parts you know I may
agree with him on the surgery part
because I don't think it's happening so
you know you seem to have started this
so I need your evidence of where these
surgeries are occurring in Tennessee
could you could you give me you know
places times maybe some names uh or
something that you know you know of yeah
I watch Mr Walsh you're recognized
my evidence is the health care
provider's own words you know I I uh I
outlined Vanderbilt health and their
transgender Care Program
and the people that work for that
program their own words talking about
what they do and talking about for
example providing the chemical
castration drugs to to adolescent
children as far as surgeries you know
double mastectomies do happen and the
way that I know that they happen is that
after I called attention to this program
at Vanderbilt they said that they were
going to stop performing they were going
to put a pause on the program that
performs these surgeries on minors and
so if you're pausing the program to
perform surgeries on minors then I'm
going to assume
that the program existed otherwise you
couldn't have paused it so now the exact
number of kids who are being subjected
to this I don't know exactly it's really
hard to come up with those numbers I
think because the people doing it aren't
really proud of it and there's not a lot
of interest on their end to tell us but
I do think that you know even one child
being horrifically mutilated is too many
so I know that it's more than one and
that's reason enough to put a stop to
this I would say
representative Mitchell you reckon yeah
so
so last week I had an amendment that you
know we're looking to protect children
from abuse and I also had an amendment
to stop cosmetic surgery of rhinoplasty
and breast enhancements to minors how
would you feel about that
you know is that mutilation of children
as well under the age of 18.
Representative Mitchell that's not on
the bill that we have
yeah it is it's surgical it's surgical I
I'm happy to
answer that
you're free to answer Mr walls okay my
personal feeling about banning breast
enhancements for for minors
yes I would be all four personally I'd
be all for Banning that absolutely yeah
representative Mitchell okay and and so
I think the previous representative you
know proved that you have no medical
background correct
uh no so so you're here probably just as
a public policy you you're trying to
address good public policy correct
represent or Mr Walsh yes so
I just have to question you know some of
your public policy you know expertise
when you know I'm reading here Singapore
is able to have nice things in part
because they execute drug dealers by
hanging and arrest even Petty vandals
and thieves and beat them with a cane
until they bleed we don't have nice
things here because we aren't willing to
do what is required to maintain them so
you know with statements like that I
kind of have to question your public
policy beliefs and you know and you also
stated there had been no studies well
I'm sitting here holding a study from
the American Academy of Pediatrics from
the University of Pittsburgh about the
uh suicidal disparities between
transgender and cisgender adults and
children so
I think you know before you state things
you may need to know all the facts
thank you all right thank you
um is that Congressman uh chairman
Williams you recognize
thank you Mr chairman I make motion go
back out of session or back into session
thank you is there an objection
all right there is
would you withdraw
my
um yes I will withdraw okay
is there any further questions for Mr
Walsh
okay see none uh thank you for your
testimony thank you okay uh okay
representative Clements who would you
like to call up
uh yes Mr chairman thank you I'm I just
have a single question for I think
the name was presha is that right
is that right yes
uh representative Clemens you are
recognized
thank you thank you Mr chairman and
thank you for coming to testify today we
appreciate it I'm curious where did you
receive your medical care North Carolina
North Carolina and did you have to
receive any counseling or psychological
evaluations or get permission of both
adults or anything before you had the
procedure at that time you're recognized
um I was in therapy for the anorexia for
a while and trying to get help for the
cutting but um when I said gender the
dialectical behavioral therapy was
stopped and um the other Psychotherapy
was stopped and I was fast tracked to
medicalization and both of my parents
were told your child has already tried
to attempt suicide if you don't affirm
her she'll succeed next time and it'll
be your fault
representative Clemens you recognize and
that was in North Carolina yes thank you
Mr thank you any further questions
um chairman farmer you reckon
yeah I think Mr chair and and thanks
again for you being here today
now how old were you when you started
the process of transitioning or this
when you said that uh your the doctor
told your parents that if you don't
transition or affirm your transition
that you would end up killing yourself
you're recognized I uh started believing
I was transgender at 15 the testosterone
started at 17
okay chairman farmer thank you do you
think do you think you would had a
things could have in your opinion
because you're live you lived it you
made those decisions or someone made
those decisions for you I guess
do you think that if you had the
opportunity to become the age of
majority 18 years old do you think that
that you would have made a different
decision or been able to make that
decision for yourself
you're recognized
um yes it's a slightly complicated
answer because of how quick gender
affirming care was and in comparison how
difficult it is to get preventative
Psychotherapy
um so I think more time would have given
me the ability to find the correct
therapy and therapist that I needed but
not being rushed would have helped a lot
too chairman farmer yeah thank you Mr
chair and I just want to say one thing
you had made the comment that you're
ugly you're not ugly you're beautiful
and we appreciate you for being here in
front of us today you're helping many
tennesseans many young folks helping us
get this initiative and this policy past
but uh you don't ever need to ever ever
don't even think you're ugly at all you
are absolutely not a you're absolutely
beautiful we appreciate if you've been
here today thank you thank you
uh chairman Kumar you recognized
thank you Mr chairman I have a question
for Dr Hamada
if there's no more for Miss Mosley uh Dr
Hamada
okay
Dr Kumar you're working on us thank you
Mr chairman thank you Dr Amala for
taking the time and courage to come and
speak on this subject my pleasure as a
physician of multiple Specialties and
also as a
socially active citizen
are you concerned that many of our large
National organizations professional
societies are politicized and are
putting out recommendations that are
self-serving to their domain I think
it's it really as a professionals who
belong to some of these societies we
should be very concerned and I wanted
your opinion about it Dr Amada
thank you Dr Kumar yes I am very
concerned about the
hard left turn that many of these
organizations have taken from the
American Medical Association the
American Psychological Association
Pediatrics OB GYN Family Medicine
Internal Medicine Etc they only
represent uh the aggressive
um gender transformations of children
and they do not put any type of breaks
on with regards to allowing them to
mature throughout childhood until they
can make some more knowledgeable
decisions
so I feel like these organizations do
not represent me and they do not even
though I'm a member of a couple of them
and they do not represent many
physicians in the United States because
I feel like they have an agenda that's
politicized
thank you thank you thank you Mr
chairman all right uh chairman face on
thank you Mr chair
Dr Amano very good to see you thank you
and I'm going to just drop a question on
you because you've been a medical doctor
you might have studied this
in the past few weeks I've been studying
what's going on in European countries
and the entire medical
people in Great Britain are starting to
walk back they've actually dissolved the
transgender clinic in Great Britain
because they see some issues obviously
and I'm wondering do you have any
knowledge of that have you seen what's
going on in Europe can you speak to this
committee from a standpoint of a doctor
and what you've seen in these Health
institutes certainly a lot of
Representative thank you
um
amazingly liberal Europe has
let me just say the United States has
com has severely exceeded even what
liberal Europe has done on many uh
facets whether it's gender
transformation or the issues of life or
the issues of euthanasia Etc
um I don't know what the problem is but
it seems like here in the United States
we are rushing to extreme positions and
with regards to this in particular the
UK Sweden and Finland have actually put
the brakes on uh with regards to these
gender transitions in our pediatric
population
you good all right representative
Clemens you recognize
yes thank you Mr chairman I I got to
take issue with your position about
these European countries I think what
you just said about finland's actually
completely false
what part well you just said that they
put the brakes on this entirely
is that accurate are you going to sit
here and testify to this committee that
Finland just put the brakes on this care
entirely
from what I understand they have slowed
down they have not they have they were
fast tracking things like this but from
what I understand they have
now they've now they're slowing down
they hadn't put the brakes on it
putting brakes on slows you down
representative recognized so
gender affirming care is available in
those countries according to my research
um
this includes both puberty blockers and
hormone replacement therapy for those 16
or older
um
in in Finland
what I've seen or what I've read is that
they're expanding their gender affirming
Care at a primary care providers making
it more accessible
Finland is actually formally legalized
the ability for its citizens to change
their gender by simply stating it and
discontinuing their mandatory
sterilization of individuals prior to
doing so
does that line up with your research
it doesn't but I've not been to Finland
I'm getting my information from the
Heritage Foundation
so I assume that they have done
significant amounts of research on that
representative Clements
yeah that's interesting okay so what was
your are you a pediatric what was your
specialty Dr homo
I am board certified and I can't even
talk Obstetrics and Gynecology as well
as family medicine with a focus on
sports medicine as well
representative Clements no Endocrinology
or Pediatrics well Pediatrics is part of
Family Medicine family medicine and then
also uh with regards to Endocrinology
that's a big portion of what we do In
Obstetrics and Gynecology and what's
your formal training in that
um four years of medical school in
residency with oral and written boards
and continued maintenance and
certification you recognize do you do
any residency in the Endocrinology yeah
thank you thank you representative
mentally you Reckless
yeah doctor and first and foremost
thanks for your service to the country
uh but you said you know these
associations and organizations like the
American Medical Association the
American
Psychiatric association the American
Academy of Pediatrics the American
Academy of Child and Adolescent
Psychiatry and the U.S Department of
Health and Human Services all I've got
letters you know advocating for gender
affirming care and the U.S Department of
Health and Human Services calling it
crucial to the overall health and
well-being for transgender youth
are all of these organizations wrong Dr
Hamada in my opinion yes they are very
wrong okay
thank you any further questions for Dr
Amada okay say none thank you
thank you uh any further questions for
our panel
all right see none without objection
we'll go back into session
later Lambert you recognize
committee thank you very much and and I
want to thank everybody that testified
and this is obviously a very passionate
and difficult issue that we grapple with
as a society so thank you all for
committee members for even considering
this bill and again I want to thank
everybody that testified these folks
feel very passionate about this issue on
both sides of it
um the question that was asked earlier
while might not have been made in the
way that we would normally ask it but it
was asked to a member of this committee
do you agree with these hormone blockers
puberty blockers these hormones Beauty
blockers or surgery being conducted on a
child someone under 18. that is the
question on how you vote today do you
agree with that or not I mean that that
is what we're doing so when you look at
all the rest of this and we've heard the
testimony from now both medical
professionals from citizens that are at
you know passionate about this and from
children and quite frankly children on
both sides of this
this bill at its core is very
straightforward okay every other
treatment that has always worked the the
treatment that these children need is
absolutely not only still on the table
but encouraged permitted and the way we
should go on this as a society it's
what's always worked when you have a
child that is not comfortable with their
adolescent body as it develops that
child gets the love support and yes many
times mental health treatment that they
need to transition through adolescence
to become adults and then they can
decide whatever they want to do but when
we're dealing with children it is simply
not good practice and not good policy to
to have doctors that will cut parts of
their body off or give them hormones or
puberty blockers that do change them
forever and do have horrible side
effects so I'm going to keep this short
the amendment specifically I know
several of you are on the subcommittee
it there were several questions about
there was a section in this bill that
dealt with abuse and collect if parents
permitted their children to undergo
these type of procedures that has been
removed from this bill there was a lot
of conversation back and forth in the
subcommittee on this and quite frankly
the goal of this bill the reason I filed
it and with all due respect to the
person that said copy and paste
obviously they don't know me we've spent
months and months and months on this
bill talking to multiple interested
parties to try to get a Tennessee a
Tennessee way to address this particular
issue and in that I
in hearing from the parent that
testified today and for many others out
there many parents they go to the doctor
with their child and their child is in
an extraordinarily difficult position
and they just want a doctor to tell them
how to make it better that's it they
just want their kid to be healthy and
happy and to be fine so we we took out
the abuse and neglect part of this and
it's simply not a part of the bill
um beyond that
I do want to say that everything that
was said about suicidal ideation
is right on the money these children
struggle with suicidal ideation these
children are going to struggle with
suicidal ideation every study has shown
that whether they go through the
surgeries whether they have the puberty
blockers or hormones or whether they do
not they are children that many times
deal with
dual diagnosis is multiple diagnoses
this isn't the only thing there is not a
silver bullet to resolve what they are
going through this bill allows for
everything else except for the
irresistible irreversible puberty
blockers hormones and surgeries for
those under 18. Mr chairman I stand
ready for questions all right thank you
uh representative Clemens you're
recognize
famous chairman I appreciate it first of
all Mr uh later I appreciate you taking
out the criminalization component
um however I of course still have some
concerns with this legislation
you know first and foremost I think my
colleague here had requested you know if
we just deal with the surgical aspect
rather than the hormonal aspects I think
this would be an entirely different
conversation but we've kind of thrown
the kitchen sink in here and it raises
some concerns so I'm just
I'm gonna touch on on the surgical
aspects first because I believe what I
saw last week was
and you can correct me if I'm wrong was
the defeat of an amendment and I think
you opposed it as well from the well
um are considered a non-friendly
amendment that would ban
optional cosmetic surgeries for minors
um
that clearly result in physical removal
of body parts that are irreversible
and so you've got gynecomastia removal
of breast tissue you got rhinoplasty
removal of bone cartilage skin you got
circumcisions you've got even micropenis
syndrome where you have hormonal
treatment at a as an infant
you don't have a problem with any of
those but you just you just want to
limit it to the specific group of people
is that right
little Lambert you recognize So you
you're a learning attorney you read
these bills the same as I do you know
what the bill says I've sponsored this
bill to address this issue if you want
to sponsor a build address all the rest
of those issues that you just mentioned
feel free we all get elected to
represent our constituents this is the
bill before you
thank you I don't want to go around
around about this it's a simple yes or
no question do you think that those
optional procedures should be allowed or
are you just targeting the specific
group of individuals who receive similar
treatment
just for a select Purpose with which you
disagree that's that's all I want
leader Lambert
so there's nothing about this that is
this year that is just yes or no I
understand that you want it to be that
simple and you can get as frustrated or
make as many faces if you want to and I
will be respectful sir you can smirk you
can laugh just as you did at many of the
witnesses this bill deals with exactly
what I said it deals with if you don't
like it the answer is to vote against it
not to demean these folks or anybody
else that has any other condition
represent Clemens okay you know if we're
not asking each no question why are you
not addressing those optional
surgeries and only these
you're recognize thank you thank you for
asking a question that is about this
bill this bill deals with the fact that
we're not going to be if this bill
passes a surgery first or a hormone or
puberty doctor first state everything
else should be tried before someone gets
to that point that's what the data shows
that's what the the actual scientific
evidence shows mental health treatment
love support guiding these children
through adolescence at least to the
point where they get to 18. there is no
evidence that surgery alone or puberty
blockers or hormone treatments alone
actually resolve their issues but these
children and their parents quite frankly
are being lied to they're being told
this one Silver Bullet will do it that's
why I brought this bill
all right represent Clemens
thank you Mr chairman and and I would
love to ask some specific questions
about the bill but the sponsor keeps
raising these issues I don't I don't
think the actual standard of care right
now in Tennessee is surgery first from
what I have learned by speaking with
people who actually know what they're
talking about and perform these type of
treatment there is a great deal of
counseling a great deal of psychological
evaluation a lot of input from the
parents requiring consent from both
parents regardless of the situation
there is an extensive process that these
families go through not just the child
the families go through this together
and so this is not a surgery first state
I think that's a just apparently false
statement and and and really does an
injustice to the to the the children and
the families
who have gone through this
now with respect to
the issue with I think the statement was
made about the the suicidal stuff I
think was brought up earlier
you know that isn't a result of these
children
um
this isn't a mental illness we're
dealing with here the the suicide and
those threats to mental illness come
from third parties we are the ones who
are creating
the problem for those children
and that's what results in in the
suicide rates
and the mental health issues and so I
think we need to be very aware of that
now with that being said I've got a
question about this grandfathering
clause in here
um you've got March 31st of 2024
in section
um
it's b1b of it's on page six top of page
six of your amended that makes the bill
I'm curious about
you're allowing children to stay on
these hormones but forces them to
de-transition by March 31st of 2024. are
you concerned about the medical
problem that may create for some of
these children
you recognize thank you sir and
specifically in the language of this
bill we are concerned to that any type
of hard stop date at the very beginning
of this without any type of stair step
down could potentially cause problems
these children are own harmful hormones
and puberty blockers and it does take
time so the time between July 1st and
March 31st would be the time that if
medically necessary those children could
be stair-stepped off of these dangerous
drugs Beyond March 31st that would no
longer be an option that was clarified
between the two again between sub and
full there's a couple of words that are
changed in that to ensure that March
31st is a hard stop on this again to be
clear these children that are already
own hormones and puberty blockers are
being harmed by them the side effects on
those we're going to lengthen
subcommittee on that exist it's not made
up it's right there on the packaging
these were not designed in many cases to
be utilized like this but when they are
used we want to make sure there's at
least a buffer there so that the doctors
can and actually look at those patients
and make a determination between July
1st and March 31st for those that had
started these
substances prior to July 1st that they
have until March 31st for a treatment
regimen that will work for them
representative Clements
um Mr chairman I may have more questions
let me get my nose together but I just
want to make one last one final plea
it's if you'd consider separating out
the hormonal treatment and from the bill
and and leave it a surgical bill I think
that would be a an entirely different
conversation
so that's my last request on that
respect thank you Mr Hunt thank you
representative Mitchell you recognized
yeah thank you Mr chairman
and laugh told you in subcommittee we we
agree
mostly on the surge surgery aspect of
this because like I said I don't think
too many genital surgeries are occurring
or any are occurring on someone under
18. but I've just got a scenario to ask
you and I'm trying to figure out how how
your bill is going to figure this out so
say you got a 16 year old child she
wants breast reduction because she wants
smaller breasts
but then you got another 16 year old
child that wants smaller breasts because
she wants to identify as a as a male
and then you got another 16 year old
child that has history of breast cancer
in the family
and it would be
best for for the uh
surgery so how are how's your bill gonna
figure out intent in those three
situations
all right
your lumberthy recognize thank you Mr
chairman again it's very clear in the
language of the bill so medical
procedure means surgical surgically
removing modifying altering or entering
into tissues cavities or organs of a
human being or prescribing administrator
under dispensing any puberty blocker
hormone to a human being and then in the
prohibitions a health care provider
shall not knowingly perform or often
perform on a minor or administer offered
to minister a minor a medical procedure
if the performance of administration of
the procedure is for the purpose of and
it goes directly too for what the
purpose is what's the purpose of
enabling a minor to identify and
identify with or live as a purported
identity inconsistent with the minor sex
or treating purported discomfort or
distress from a discordance between the
minor sex and asserted identity and then
it goes on with the exceptions beyond
that representative Mr chairman so
you're saying you know if someone just
comes in and just lies to the position
to the plastic surgeon it's okay
so that's what you're setting up
am I am I correct in that uh you
recognize no sir that's what you're
saying what I said was the language of
the bill well but I'm talking about
realities and and that's what's going to
happen but again you know committee
again
we went through this last week
the surgery aspect of his bill is fine
let's pass that but when you get to
these hormone therapy and puberty
blockers and things like that that's
where it comes into the area where
representative Faison up there suggested
I don't want to be part of anything
that's going to increase the suicide
rate in children in the state uh you
know I'm reading here from Health and
Human Services puberty blockers
reversible uh
hormone therapy reversible gender
affirming surgeries not reversible
so I think you know we can put a hold on
something until somebody turns 18 that's
not reversible but the others folks
I don't want to be a part of of raising
the suicide rate in this state
especially for a child and we're getting
into an area where
we're hearing a lot of testimony from
people who are not doctors who are not
psychologists who are not psychiatrists
but they're getting a lot of clicks
and that's not how we do legislation in
this state we look out for the
well-being of the citizens of this state
especially the children
and I think part of his bill does that
part of his bill harms children so I I
think this committee needs to do the
right thing thanks thank you uh leader
Lambert you can respond thank you Mr
chairman
with all the respects are a portion of
what you said is just absolutely
inaccurate and this is not an opinion
this is fact you may want to take it and
spin it some other way I I understand
that you're very depth at at advocating
for your position you always have been a
2011 study that examined a 30-year
outcome revealed 10 to 15 years after
surgical reassignment the suicide rate
of those who had undergone sex
reassignment surgery Rose to 20 times
that of comparable peers these children
are being lied to we do agree at least
on the surgical aspect of this the
hormones and the puberty blockers you've
heard from two different people of what
that causes to them the the actual pain
the side effects the mental anguish that
it causes from them that is not being
fully explained by every doctor and I
won't throw them all into the same
basket
it's not too much to ask so that the
suicidal ideation rate does not increase
in these children that they wait till at
least 18. we're talking a couple of
years here for most of them so they can
go through adolescence and here's the
other reason
there's plenty of other evidence that at
least tens of there's 10 separate
studies and I can get you all this as
much as you'd like that indicates more
than 80 percent of the children who meet
the correct this criteria for gender
affirming care will outgrow gender
dysphoria and embrace their biological
sex we just need to give them time and
give them the support and the in the
love and the mental health treatment
that they need and it is a mental health
condition it has always been a mental
health condition it is about how you
feel about your body the best outcome is
that you feel comfortable in your body
and then that actually does reduce
suicidal ideation so at the end of the
day that's all I'm asking of this
committee let's at least wait to their
adults representative Hammer you
recognized
I'm going on representative
representative
thank you Mr chairman uh thank you uh Mr
uh leader I was curious uh from your
research is there anything you said
there's no Silver Bullet but is there
any best practices or uh or other
evidence-based guidelines that that can
and does help this population
yes absolutely and thank you for asking
that question again mental health
support identifying what the problem is
I mean actually
spending months and even years with
these children through those therapy
sessions just as we heard testimony
today to see if there is another
diagnosis that is driving this thought
process some sometimes it is autism that
is one of the most misdiagnosis that
occurs many times when a child goes into
a doctor's office and and they're
diagnosed with gender dysphoria many
times it's actually autism and somewhere
on that Spectrum other times it's any
variety of other issues that have come
up sometimes it can be triggered by as
we heard testimony from
um something that has happened to that
child sometimes an abuse or an attack or
something else that has occurred but in
mental health treatment for as long as
possible before you go into surgical
intervention or medical intervention is
absolutely the tried and true practice
and what other countries are starting to
move back to
good all right um chairman Williams
you're recognize
question on the bill
the question has been called on the bill
seeing no objection we are voting on
House Bill one
all those in favor say aye aye
opposed no eyes have it bill goes on to
Civil Justice thank you Mr chair members
of the committee all right thank you
um before we adjourn I personally would
like to thank all those that came and
testified I think particularly those
that have been patients uh shows a lot
of courage and I appreciate your coming
and participating in this
in this process and if you want to have
your vote recorded as a no please notify
the clerk seeing no further business
before us we are adjourned